guten morgen buddies today I'm filming
from Dortmund Germany where I am on a
mini break with my mate we came out here
for a few gluhwein it was a last-minute
decision we did a kind of travel
roulette and whilst of that have also
been doing a little bit of working kind
of digital Nomad style except not really
digital nomads because I'm going home at
the end of the weekend to see my wife
because I miss her so I'm not really a
digital nomad as such because I'm going
home at the end of the weekend but one
nice perk about working online is the
fact that I can go out midweek to seven
part of the world if I say wish if we
can get cheap travel and work from there
as long as they've got Wi-Fi and that
power socket I'm good to go and I
thought I'd show you a few the items
that use in order to work and travel
more conveniently and maybe in the
future I might do one I'm working out as
a travel but for now this is how you
work in to travel with a couple of items
the Dell Venue Pro 8 this is a 8 inch
Windows tablet runs full Windows 10 so
you can run word on it and everything
else that's not Windows RT it's not an
arm tablet it's a proper computer so I
can also run basic for Android or
Android studio to do some programming
and build apps anything you can do on a
computer you can do on this also has a
nice little keyboard touchscreen means
you don't need the mouse although I did
also bring a small mouse the Microsoft
wedge Mouse which is a very nice one
this is part of my daily carry as well I
use that Mouse on the go at home so then
we can flip this over they magnetically
attached and I don't have big enough
trousers on me right now but that would
actually fit into a coat pocket or very
large trouser pockets so you can be
completely hands-free and able to work
on the gear in the battery lasts for
about five hours I think so pretty handy
little device and a massive upgrading
carrying even a slim laptop or a MacBook
Air with you a Kindle I kinda number
which make Kindle this is satisfactory
right now but the reason to carry one of
these is that they give you emergency 3G
if you really need it amazon offers free
3G wherever you are in the world because
they won't use download their books
there's a loss leader and they make a
profit from it I don't know if every
model of Kindle has a browser built in
but this one does and it also has a
keyboard so if I'm stuck in the middle
in there and I have no internet access
and I really needed to speak to a client
or that someone know where I was then I
can get on to my gmail on that there's a
very cheap device and the battery lasts
for literally ever although I have
matter when it houses about timing and
the e-ink display means you can sit on a
sunny beach and still be browsing on the
web without glare or anything like that
so that's a really handy little thing to
carry and it fits into any small bag
very easy traveling with who wishes not
to be named or appear on camera I am
here with someone I'm not just drinking
gluhwein on my own yeah there is truth
he says that only the first couple of
generations or maybe even only the very
first generation has the free browser
and 3G the others only let you download
ebooks so if you do want to use this as
a little traveling hack then make sure
you get the older version identify still
selling them but I'm sure you can get
them on eBay
next up and microfiber towel this was a
gift from a friend recently it also
travels a lot and a great thing about
this is that it's a whole towel it's
it's slightly smaller than full-size I
think but it fits into this tiny little
pouch and it's made of a really thin
material that dries incredibly quickly
so instead of having to carry around
you're going to be staying in a hostel
or somewhere that might not provide a
towel instead of having to carry around
something massive in a bag this is again
small enough to fit in the pocket or
just into a small shoulder bag always
think you should carry an ink pad forget
second screening maybe at home you have
a multiple monitor array you can't do
that at home but if you just got a
notepad and a pen you can drop down
ideas as you go and you can do maths
working out right down passwords and
things
also when you're out and back you have
an ID you can jot it down doesn't need
to boot up or anything actually think
carrying a notepad has a ton of
advantages in daily life as well I write
down ideas I have for Christmas presents
on here when I hear people would mention
them and then I always have a good list
of things to get people when November or
December come around so yeah always
carry a notepad I think and again very
small very light and you can take it
anyway isn't an hour battery either and
if you meet you can do your writing on
your notepad wherever you are and then
type it up when you get home that's
another tip if you are not battery this
is Iron Man Tony Stark keeps me inspired
so I could bring him and stand him
wherever I am and he gives me the
motivation to come up with genius app
ideas and write about technology in a
good way man bag that I carry everywhere
this can fit all the stuff in it and you
can hang it over your shoulder and it's
tiny if you can even I find I can even
get onto an airplane using this as a
extra hand luggage no one ever said
anything to me about it because it's so
small keep your passport in here so it's
safe under your arm and it doesn't get
in the way if you want to be running
around or climbing on stuff and yeah
I've been told by my friend it looks
like I'm a Polish tourist but I am half
polish so that's fine this is form over
nope
yes it's function over form so don't
worry if you look a little bit like a
tourist because you know jokes on them
you've got all your stuff around under
your armpit
which is where you want it and for my
main bag I don't have one much bigger
this is what I travel with
it's tiny but it's all you need so yeah
that's everything that's my little pack
of things I need to work with obviously
I have adapter and plug as well and as
long as I've got those things and
wherever I am and in the world I can
plug in and I can get to work
obviously I also carry my phone the
Galaxy Note 4 which is filming this it
also comes in handy a lot and there are
lots of other things you can do I could
say that I haven't mentioned and I'd
love to hear what you carry maybe some
kind of wireless dongle is something I'm
missing from my kit so how about you
guys
thanks for watching and hope you enjoyed
this video stay tuned for the next one
bye for now so this is the bustling city
of Dortmund yeah it's normally a lot
more exciting than that genuinely on the
Saturday and the Friday it was very good
we had lots of gluhwein and beer
everything is closed on a Sunday in
Germany for some reason but this is cool
this is the biggest Christmas tree in
the world yeah apparently it's made of
lots of smaller Christmas trees so yeah
happy Christmas it's not just natural
and just grow like that because I would
have been really difficult for somebody
to cut down and bring here but yeah so
my friend who was filming earlier he's a
pilot and he can get us cheap flights
anywhere we picked wherever was
available last minute so on the morning
we didn't know where we're gonna go and
then we ended up in Dortmund and it's
been a really cool weekend and yeah
because he's a pilot and because I'm
freelance working online we can do that
sort of thing so yeah it's one of the
big perks if you work online and you're
able to work from anywhere